have you digested like the fact that you
are now
a phenomenon as Wednesday I would not
call myself fat uh but I'm gonna call
you that I definitely feel like there's
been a shift in my life and I feel it's
just an energy and change and I feel
like it's definitely a new time in my
life so it's it's been a bit of an
adjustment the dance did you know that
it would go viral crazy viral no
I believe because it was kind of on some
of it I some of the moves I had planned
some of it was improv that was one of
the scenes that I stay awake at night
thinking about because I thought there
was so much that I should have done and
could have done so the fact that anybody
has shown any bit of appreciation or
have even tried it themselves is kind of
um it's not fathomable to me do you go
down the tick tock rabbit hole and look
at all the people doing it no I can't be
on Tick Tock I can't I can't look into
all of that stuff I I think good or bad
it's probably not a healthy place to be
what's happening with Scream Six
Scream 6 is coming out in March I'm
pretty excited it's pretty gory yeah it
takes place in New York we shot it last
July June July August in Montreal I'm
very very excited for people as well I
mean this franchise being a part of it
now it's so iconic has that can be
wrapped your head around that because
you guys were like the new kids before
yeah I yeah there was a lot of pressure
coming into that especially because my
role was initially kind of doing a spin
on Drew Barrymore's part which is
obviously legendary I think because I've
sat with the I've sat with the project
for long enough I've kind of been able
to to accept it and I said but it's
still such an honor to work with someone
like Ghostface is a it's a dream you
look handsome very much we have all gone
mad about Wednesday how mad have you
gone
I think we're both uh we've both been
driven pretty mad I would say I mean the
phenomena
I can rarely ever figure out what's
happening but
um I think I'm very proud and very
excited
um every day when I wake up and remember
so and you guys have gotten to be really
close friends in the making of this I
mean everybody kind of feels like family
with you all right yeah we I we got
really really lucky it's kind of
unbelievable
um and it's nice we're still in contact
with our entire cast pretty much every
day it's um it's been a really nice time
foreign